it looks like Hilary Duff may have a new  man if you love him  the younger star was photographed  packing on the PDA over the weekend in  Malibu California as for the tall dark  and handsome man that's Eli Sandvik CEO  of an energy consulting company on  Saturday the duo was all smiles as they  took a dip in the ocean  Hillary showed off her fit physique in a  black two-piece suit oh yeah  the next day Eli was snapped carrying  the 29 year old actress through the  water on his shoulders this time she  opted for a pink bikini based on Duff's  snapchat it appears even her pups were  along for the romantic beach weekend  stuff was last linked to  singer/songwriter Matthew koma in  January they split after only a few  months her divorce from ex-husband Mike  Comrie was finalized last February